les rues de bogota plongée dans le chaos
pour la huitième journée de
manifestations anti-gouvernementales
placée sous le signe de la grève
nationale
de nouvelles violences ont éclaté dans
la capitale les forces de l'ordre ont eu
recours à des gaz lacrymogènes et aux
canons à eau contre les manifestants
alors que ces derniers tentaient de
pénétrer dans le parlement ce mercredi
le président colombien ivan bouquet a
accusé des narcotrafiquants d'être
derrière ces violences
elle banalise moins extrêmement ya le
terrorisme urban le vandalisme extrême
est le terrorisme urbain que nous
observons sont financé et organisé par
les mafias du trafic de drogue comme l'a
dénoncé le procureur général de la
nation
nous avons mal pour tous ceux qui ont
été victimes de la violence de ces
jours-ci tous les colombiens rejette
sans ambiguïté les actes violences les
attaques contre les infrastructures les
barrages routiers qui empêchent
l'approvisionnement et la nourriture
d'arriver dans les foyers des familles
colombiennes